are mom bods next are mombots ever going
to be a thing i would wish to live in a
world where my mom stretches ourselves
cellulite
cellulite saggy boobs like where all
that is a thing i would love that
instead of victoria's secret's kind of
doing that a little bit like that the
whole ashley graham thing oh sure she's
she's thick with several seeds she's a
trendsetter i love that lizzo is lizzo
ever going to be i love that woman this
is hot you think so she's hot in her own
way yeah yeah in her own way okay yeah
but so aren't i ever going to be a thing
like that
that's about like women being coming in
different shapes and sizes okay that's
they're still young and like you're
thirty do you know what listen as women
you know how powerful we are we
literally hold the portal to life yeah
no objection there we hold the portal to
life
in between our legs like how powerful is
that yeah all right so any woman
watching this who doesn't know how
powerful she is now you know wow okay
on top of that in that transformation
our body changes
also and what we need is more men to
come out and appreciate our
transformation
we need to appreciate for ourselves but
men need to appreciate that too because
you're walking the street yes a
beautiful woman's going to walk by but
has she birthed your child
has she breastfed your child
like it's what comes with it i just hold
it real quick i just want to i just i
got to say
mom i appreciate you i love you i'm
thinking of you right now for the for
the single ladies out there i love my
mom i appreciate i have a great
relationship with my mom much like
leonardo dicaprio i will take my mom to
the oscars
in between my mom's legs is the cradle
of life yes respect
that's where you came out of it thank
you i appreciate that so
shout out to the moms out there and
shout out to jenny for just crushing
that little thing right there yeah you
killed it i um
i'm kind of speechless right there jenny
that was like a very uh those it was
that was good stuff right that was a
segment ender that was a segment i think
we can move on right you gotta
transition
[Music]